انطلاق القمه العربيه الثانيه 32 في جده
خلال ساعات في اجواء تؤكد عوده الجسور
المفتوحه بين دول المنطقه على قاعده
التضامن والمصالح
تحذيرات من غارات جويه وهجمات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات على مناطق مختلفه في اوكرانيا
والعاصمه
اجتماعاتهم في اليابان قاده مجموعه الشباب
على قلب رجل واحد في عقوباتهم دروسها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تنطلق خلال ساعات في جده القمه
العربيه العاديه في دورتها 32
وسط اجواء تفاؤليه وتوافقيه وتعويل على ان
تنعكس نتائجها ايجابا على معظم الملفات
الساخنه ومن المقرر ان تركز اجنده القمه
على عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
بالاضافه الى العلاقات العربيه مع دول
الجوار وكذلك الوضع المتفجر في السودان
والقضيه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس بشار الاسد كان هنا قبل 13 عاما
التقى مع الملك الراحل عبد الله بن عبد
العزيز ثم غاب وغابت بلاده غابت في حرب
داخليه دمويه
يعود الرئيس بشار الاسد الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وتعود بلاده الى جامعه الدول العربيه في
رحله استغرقت اثني عشر عاما
الجزائر والعراق وفلسطين هذه الدول لم
تقطع علاقاتها مع سوريا منذ البدايه في
العام 2014 تونس تفتح الباب باعلان فتح
مكتب قنصلي لها في دمشق
عام 2018
تطور كبير وزير خارجيه سوريا يزور عمان
الاردن يفتح المعابر الحدوديه الرئيس
السوداني السابق عمر البشير يزور دمشق
والامارات والبحرين تعيدان فتح سفارتيهما
في دمشق
بدايه العام الحالي
2023 وبعد 12 عاما من القطيعه زلزال مدمر
يضرب سوريا وتركيا الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي يتصل ببشار الاسد وتبادل للزيارات
بين الطرفين
والسعوديه تستقبل وزير الخارجيه السوري
فيصل المقداد ثم ترد الزياره بمثلها الى
دمشق
الشرور التي احاطت ببعض الدول العربيه
انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي انعكست على
الواقع العربي كان الواقع العربي غير سار
فاصبح واقعا ماسويا
10 دول عربيه اخرى تنتظر ما سيصدر عن
جامعه الدول العربيه
لاعاده تقييم علاقاتها مع سوريا فيما
تتمسك دول اخرى بموقفها الرافض لعوده
العلاقات
ولكن كيف ينظر الشارع العربي للقمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في جده
[موسيقى]
كيف ينظر الشارع العربي الى القمه العربيه
الثانيه 32 في جده سالنا بدايه الشارع
السعودي عن دور الرياض المستمر في راس
الصدع العربي نشاهد
السعوديه دائما سباقه فعل الخير سواء في
الدول العربيه او الدول الاجنبيه بالذات
الدول الشقيقه العربيه السعوديه تقوم بدور
جبار وعظيم لحل المشاكل السياسيه
والاقتصاديه دائما سباكه في حل خلافاتها
بين الدول ان كان في ازمه اليمن ان كان في
ازمه السودان وان كان في ازمه فلسطين
[موسيقى]
مصر تمر بازمه اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه
بالاضافه الى خلاف مع اثيوبيا فيما يتعلق
بسد النهضه والامن المائي هل المصريون
متفائلون ان تمد لهم قمه جده يد العون
احنا بنتطلع ان العربي يساعدونا
في يعني الازمه الاقتصاديه احنا الازمه
الاقتصاديه طبعا زي ما بنطلع من الاخوه
العرب يعني دايما يسندونا ولكن احنا لازم
نسند نفسينا لا بصراحه لان لو كانت هتساعد
كان سعد قبل كده في القيم العربيه السابقه
يعني بنتمنى اللي هو يتحل يعني ونتملى
يبقى الحل على على ايدين الاجتماع اللي
هيحصل ونتمنى يبقى السعوديه وش الخير يعني
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
يعيشوا لبنان ازمه ماليه خانقه واخرى
سياسيه تتمثل بانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه ما
رايو الشارع اللبناني حول قدره القمه
العربيه على مساعده بلادهم
[موسيقى]
استثنائيه بمكان استثنائي بقياده
استثنائيه واليوم الدوره عم تلعب المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على المستوى العربي لم
الشمل هذا بالنسبه لنا شيء حدث تاريخي
المهم انه يتفقوا مع بعضهم للشعب يرتاح
عرفت كيف لانه البلد ما بقى بيتحمل انت
بدك تساعد اذا مساعد حالك ما حدا بيساعدك
اما العراق فيشهدوا تجاذبات سياسيه
واقتصاديه عده لكنه بدا يعود تدريجيا الى
المشهد العربي سياسيا واقتصاديا الشارع
العراقي هل يعول على القمه العربيه الثاني
والثلاثين في جده الكثير دعونا نشاهد
اما بالسعوديه يعني انا اعتبرها هذا
انتصار للامه العربيه بكاملها لانه الان
خاصه القمه راح تهتم بوضع العراق وضعه
سياسي وضع الاقتصادي وهاي مبادره حلوه من
اخوتنا سعوديين في هذا المجال لان
السعوديه دائما تدعم الشعب العربي جميعا
وهذا مبادره كلش جيده نتامل من السعوديه
خير تمد يدعون للعراق وتتعاون وهي بادرت
باكثر من مشروع تجاري او زراعي او كهربائي
[موسيقى]
امال كبيره يعقدها الشارع العربي على
القمه العربيه في جده لانهاء الازمات
في العالم العربي وسط تفاؤل حذر يبديه
البعض تجاه هذه القمه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
من مدينه جده العربيه
رغم ان غالبيه القمم العربيه التي عقدت
طوال العقود الماضيه ارتبطت مسمياتها
بالمدن التي عقدت بها الا ان بعضا منها
انطلق بمسميات ارتبطت بالاحداث المتزامنه
مع العقادها او الظروف التي عقدت خلالها
[موسيقى]
القمم العربيه غالبيتها سميت باسماء المدن
المستضيفه واخرى بالظروف التي تعصف
بالعالم العربي
منها قمه اللاءات الثلاث
عقدت في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
يونيو
1967 عقب عدوان يونيو واحتلال اسرائيل
الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه والجولان وسيناء
القمه السداسيه عقدت في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض في العام
بمبادره من السعوديه والكويت لبحث الازمه
في لبنان قمه الوفاق والاتفاق عقدت في
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان في العام
1987 واطلق عليها هذا الاسم لتعكس الرغبه
في ان تكون القمه للوفاق العربي والاتفاق
قمه الاقصى قمه استثنائيه عقدت في القاهره
في العام 2000 وذلك بعد شهر من اندلاع
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه
قمه التضامن عقدت في الرياض في العام 2007
وجرى خلالها التاكيد على الالتزام بالسلام
العادل والشام كخيار استراتيجي
قمه القدس
اطلق عليها الملك سلمان هذا الاسم حيث قال
في كلمته ليعلم القاصي والداني ان فلسطين
وشعبها في وجدان العرب والمسلمين
قمه لم الشمل عقدت في الجزائر في نوفمبر
2022 وهي الاولى بعد انقطاع دام نحو ثلاث
سنوات
بدات بعضويه سبعه دول في العام
1945 وانتهت باثنتين وعشرين دوله عربيه
جامعتهم جامعه الدول العربيه لتحقيق
الاهداف المشتركه وتوحيد الصف تجاه مسرح
الاحداث الاقليميا ودوليا نتعرف على
المراحل الاولى لتاسيس جامعه الدول
العربيه قبل نحو ثمانيه عقود في التقرير
التالي
من الخليج العربي شرقا وحتى المحيط
الاطلسي غربا كانت جامعه الدول العربيه
لنحو ثمانيه عقود حاضره ومظله للدول
العربيه وشعوبها في الازمات فعلى طاولتها
ناقش العرب اصعب قضاياهم الشائكه
تاريخيا يعود تاسيس جامعه الدول العربيه
الى مارس من العام
1945 لتكون بذلك الاقدم بين المنظمات
العربيه والاقليميه والدوليه منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فقبيل التاسيس كان العالم يعيش مرحله
حساسه انعكست بطبيعه الحال على المنطقه
فمن ناحيه كانت بوادر نهايه الحرب فرصه
مواتيه لتكاتف الجهود ما اسهم في استقلال
عدد من الدول العربيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
تعززت الحاجه الى الوحده في ظل بروز مخاطر
اقليميه وما صاحب هذه المرحله من احتكاك
متزايد بالغرب ومعاصره تطور النظام الدولي
كلها كانت عوامل محفزه لظهور الجامعه
العربيه التي ولدت فعليا بتوقيع بروتوكول
الاسكندريه عام
1944 حيث كان اساس ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه لاحقا والذي وقعته سبع دول هي مصر
وسوريا والسعوديه وشرق الاردن ولبنان
والعراق واليمن ومن الدول السبع اتسعت
الرقعه الجغرافيه لعضويه الجامعه العربيه
لتشمل حتى الان اثنتين وعشرين دوله جمعتها
طاولتها المستديره في الظروف العاديه
والطارئه باهداف مشتركه تصب لتحقيق
المصالح وتوحيد الصف تجاه مسرح الاحداث
اقليميا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وسنكوف معكم في تغطيه مباشره لكل التفاصيل
المتعلقه بقمه جدا اليوم هذه نشره مستمره
وفيها بعد الفاصل
خطا واهمال مقاول روسي يكشف عن مخبئ
بوتانا سري في حال وقوعي حرب النوويه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه النشره اصدر
الجيش الاوكراني تحضيرات من وقوع
غاراتيه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا باستثناء
المناطق الغربيه وحضر الجيش من ضربات
صاروخيه محتمله في
اوديسايف الجنوبيتين كما ورد تحضيرات من
هجمات بطائرات مسيره في كييف وفي مناطق
غرب العاصمه
يعقد قاده مجموعه السبع الكبرى القمه
المقرره في مدينه هيروشيما خلال ساعات
القادمه والتي تستمر لثلاثه ايام للاتفاق
حول تجديد العقوبات على روسيا والبحث في
سبل مواجهه القوه العسكريه والاقتصاديه
المتناميه للصين وفي شان العقوبات اعلن
مسؤولا في الاداره الامريكي عن جهود مهمه
تهدف الى تقييد وصول روسيا الى حد كبير
المنتجات الضروريه لتعزيز قدراتها
القتاليه واضاف ان هذه الاجراءات ستمنع
نحو 70 كيانا من روسيا ودول اخرى من
الحصول على صادرات الامريكيه عبر ادراجها
في اللائحه التجاريه السوداء وقال الرسول
انه سيتم فرض نحو 300 عقوبه جديده ضد
افراد وقيادات وسفن وطائرات رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارلي قال بدوره ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيستهدف تجاره الالماس الروسيه
في اطار السعي الى تضييق قدره موسكو على
تمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا كما اعلنت
الحكومه البريطانيه ان رئيس الوزراء
يعتزم الاعلان عن حظر الالماس وواردات
المعادن روسيا بما في ذلك النحاس
والالمنيوم والنيكل كما ستستهدف بريطانيا
بالعقوبات 86 شخصيه وشركه روسيه من المجمع
الصناعي العسكري الموالي للرئيس فلاديمير
قدمت الخارجيه السودانيه مذكره احتجاج
لحكومه جنوب السودان على خلفيه سماحها
لمستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت
بزياره جبا ونقلت وسائل الاعلام السودانيه
عن الوزاره استغرابها لهذا التصرف الذي
قام من خلاله يوسف عزت بعقد اجتماع بحضور
مسؤولين كبار من حكومه جمهوريه جنوب
السودان نفعلها هامشه الاخبار المتداوله
بشان استخدام الدعم السريع المواطنين
كطروع بشركه
السيده سناء محمود واحده من امهات كثر
يخشون على اطفالهم من اثار الاقتتال
المندلع في الخرطوم منذر ابريل الماضي
والذي قضى فيه اكثر من 190 طفلا بحسب
اليونيسف
[تصفيق]
بدموع وخوف تبكي هذه السيده كلما هلع
طفلاها عند سماع ايه اصوات مجاوره طرقات
خفيفه كثيره باعادتهما الى ويلات حرب لم
ترحم براءه الطفوله نجت عائلتها من
الاقتتال الدائر في الخرطوم وانتقلت الى
بر الامان في القاهره لكن مشهد الموت لم
يغب عن ذاكرتها بالليل بتتعيد
سناء واسرتها مثال على شعب استفاق على نار
الاقتتال وبارود الموت
مئه وتسعون طفلا دفعوا حياتهم ظلما في اول
عشره ايام من الحرب
و368 الفا باتوا بلا ماوى ولا تعليم بحسب
اليونيسف
لدينا بالفعل 611 طفلا دون سن الخامسه
يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحادي الوخيمه
ويعاني ثلاثه ملايين طفل دون سن الخامسه
من سوء التغذيه بشكل عام
هذا المكان الذي يقع في مدينه بورسودان
على البحر الاحمر بات ملجا للفارينه من
ضربات الموت امتار صغيره صارت فسحه
ترفيهيه للاطفال علها تمحو ما رسمته الحرب
من مئاس مروعه
سواد قاتم يخيم على مشهد الاقتتال المندلع
في السودان منذ اكثر من شهر لكن الواضح ان
اعداد الضحايا والمكلومين اخذتم بالارتفاع
واستخرق تام من الطرفين في حمايه براءه
الطفوله وتوفير متطلبات الحياه
قال رئيس مجلس نواب الجمهوري كيفن انه
يتوقع تحقيقا انفراج في المحادثات من اجل
التوصل الى اتفاق لرفع سقف الدين العام
بشكل يتيح للولايات المتحده تفادي التخلف
عن سداد ديونها من جانبها حضرت وزاره
الخزانه من عواقب وخيمه بسبب تلك الازمه
قد تؤدي الى دفع الاقتصاد الامريكي نحو
الركود
بيظل الازمه القائمه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين حول رفع سقف الدين العام
البالغ واحد وثلاثين تريليون و400 مليار
دولار يتعقد المشهد خاصه مع اقتراب
الحكومه الفيدراليه من الحد القانوني
المسموح به للاقتراض من اجل سد عجز
الميزانيه
الخلافات واضحه بين الحزبين فالجمهوريين
يطالبون بخفض الانفاق الحكومي في عدد من
القطاعات بينما يرى الديمقراطيون ان خفض
الانفاق سيؤثر على قطاعات امنت لهم عددا
كبيرا من الاصوات في الانتخابات السابقه
الانتخابات السابقه باصوات الشباب وذوي
الدخل المنخفض وهو لا يريد ان يخسر هذا
الامتياز قبل الانتخابات المقبله المصيريه
بالنسبه للديمقراطيين
الجمهوريون حددوا بعض المجالات المحتمله
للاتفاق وهي اصلاح التصاريح لمشاريع
الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه والغاء الاعفاءات
الضريبيه للطاقه النظيفه تشديد متطلبات
العمل لبرامج المساعدات الفيدراليه قطاع
التعليم والبرامج الاجتماعيه الغاء اموال
كوفي 19 غير المنفقه وامام هذه المطالب
يحاول الديمقراطيون فرض التعديل الرابعه
عشر في هذه القضيه الخلافيه منعا لتقييد
سقف الدين باي تخفيضات قد تؤثر على
شعبيتهم في الداخل
يجب على الرئيس ان يلجا الى التطبيق
التعديل الرابع عشر لا للمفاوضات مع من
يريد ان تتخلف الولايات المتحده عن دفع
ديونها نحن دائما نفي بالتزاماتنا لا
لتخفيض سقف الدين العام هذا امر غير مقبول
انا وزملائي وقعنا على وثيقه تطالب الرئيس
بتطبيق التعديل الرابع عشر الان
استخدام التعديل الرابع عشر سيفتح تحديات
قضائيه كبيره امام البيت الابيض الامر
الذي يتخ
وف من بايدن الذي يحاول ان يتفاوض في
الساعات الاخيره مع المحافظين للتوصل الى
حل يمنع الولايات المتحده من التخلف عن
تفعيل ديونها سليمان العربيه واشنطن
كشف موقع الدوره الاخباريه الامريكيه
تفاصيل عن مخبئ بوتينه سري عقب اعاده
تفسير مخططات مقاول الروسي نشرها على
موقعه الخاص للترويج لاعماله مطلع عام
2010 مخططات بقيت متاحه على الانترنت حتى
اواخر 2016
روسيا فلاديمير بوتين وهو جالس يستعرض
قدرات بلده النوويه يدرك حد اليقين ان اي
حرب تستعمل فيها هذه الاسلحه ستكون مدمره
قد تهدد وجوده شخصيا على سطح الكوكب
مخبا سري لدى زعيم الكرملين يوجد تحت مجمع
فاخر يقع فوق منطقه منحدره تطل على البحر
الاسود المكان مخصص لمواجهه احتمال حدوث
حرب نوويه حسب موقع بيزنس
المجمع تبلغ مساحته 190 الف قدم مربع
وتكلفته مليار دولار يقع على منحدر واعر
يتمتع بكل رفاهيه يمكن ان يرغب فيها بوتين
المخبئ السري لبوتين اسفل مجمعه يتكون من
نفقين منفصلين يمكن الوصول اليهما عبر
مصعد كهربائي يهبط اكثر من 50 مترا تحت
السطح النفقان مغلقان بالاسمنت السميك
ومزودان بما يكفي من الماء العذب والتهويه
اللازمه ومقصورات واسعه لخدمه الشخصيات
المهمه لايام بل لاسابيع النفق السفلي
يؤدي الى ممر متحرك يقود الى الخارج يضم
كافه انواع الامن والسلامه النفقان مجهزان
بانظمه للحريق والمياه والمياه المجاري
كلها ترمي لكي يكون الشخص على قيد الحياه
او يتمكن من الهرب
الاستعداد للحرب النوويه بمخابئ محصنه لا
يخص بوتين فحسب بل لدى الزعماء في كل
الدول النوويه خطه الطوارئ القصوى في حال
اندلاع حرب مدمره بمن فيهما الرئيس
الامريكي الذي توجد مخابئه النوويه تحت
البيت الابيض وفي ولايه فيرجينيا بلال
الوجداني العربيه
بعد عمليه جراحيه معقده استغرقت اكثر من
14 ساعه تمكن فريق طبي سعودي بقياده
الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه من فصل التوام
السيامي النيجيري حسانه وحسين واوضح
الدكتور عبد الله ربيع ان عمليه فصل توام
السيامي نفذت على 8 مراحل وتعد هذه
العمليه رقم 56 للمراه السعودي لفصل
التوامه
في الختام تذكير بالعناوين
انطلاق القمه العربيه 32 في جده خلال
ساعات في اجواء تؤكد عوده الجسور المفتوحه
بين الدول المنطقه على قاعده التضامن
والمصالح
تحضيرات النغارات الجويه وهجمات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات على مناطق مختلفه في اوكرانيا
والعاصمه
مع باب اجتماعات في اليابان قاده مجموعه
السبع على قلب رجل واحد في عقوباتهم ضد
روسيا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات